à 4 jours du coup d'envoi de la Coupe du
monde de rugby l'équipe de France est
touchée par une polémique concernant
Bastien chalureau le deuxième ligne de
Montpellier avait été condamné pour des
violences à caractère raciste en 2020 il
a fait appel et pour répondre aux
suscité par sa présence en bleu il a
pris la parole hier il s'est défendu de
tout racisme jusqu'à fondre en larmes
premier jour je le dis
j'ai réfuté ces accusations
voilà je suis pas raciste depuis
quelques secondes plus tard
chalureux il a joué un équipe de France
en novembre 2022 en Afrique contre
l'Afrique du Sud première cape il joue
le 18 novembre contre le Japon deuxième
cap que dit elle est fille rien il fait
le Tournoi de France Gall toujours pas
dans les filles il est pris à Marcoussis
en préparation de la Coupe du monde
en juin 2023 pas un mot la France
insoumise ignore les lois de ce pays la
France insoumise rend la justice sur
Twitter elle rétablit les comités de
salut public les petits nouveaux
docteurs guillotins prennent le modèle
sur le sanguinaire Maral ami du peuple
sous la Terreur l'homme qui dressait des
listes et envoyé tout à chacun sur
l'échafaud à 4 jours de France le black
les six copentes de l'extrême gauche est
ma rendre l'atmosphère de ce pays
irrespirable le 3 juillet il va à
l'entraînement à Monaco préparation pour
le pour la Coupe du Monde pas un mot le
12 août il joue français cosse pas un
mot le 19 août joue France Fidji pas un
mot et là à cinq jours de l'événement le
plus important parce que match décisif
d'entrer d'entrer on va aller uniquement
pour sa gueule et faire parler un peu de
soi et du buzz pour son petit parti on
va aller taper sur chalure rouge un
joueur de rugby donc qui pleure en
conférence de presse ce n'est pas banal
ce n'est pas banal mais cette séquence
ce n'est pas très raccord avec celle du
coach assis à la même place la veille
sur le même sujet la Coupe du Monde
c'est pas pour les movies est-ce que
vous croyez que les gens qui jouent au
rugby ne se parlent pas est-ce que vous
croyez que les hommes qui vont aller au
combat là contre les All Blacks ne se
parle pas et ne sont pas capables de
mettre tout à plat ça a été fait depuis
bien longtemps donc accusé chalureux
c'est aussi accusé l'équipe de France de
légèreté et je pense pas que l'équipe de
François légère elle va nous le montrer
contre le blocks dénonciation et
lynchage sont leurs armes favorites sauf
évidemment quand l'un des leurs est au
cœur d'une polémique Adrien catenas à
droite plus des gares quand il tabasse
son épouse ainsi marche la France
insoumise aujourd'hui c'est chaleureux
demain la meute trouvera un autre client
la soif d'exécution publique de ces gens
et inépuisable est-ce que Ségolène Royal
peut représenter la gauche aujourd'hui
voilà c'est tout
j'ai droit à un joker dans cette
émission
après la promesse de don hier de 10
millions d'euros par Bernard Arnault au
resto du coeur c'est de fils Antoine et
Frédéric sont venus signer leur chèque
au siège de l'association en présence de
Robert G ministre des salariés
à celui de l'État et d'autres
entreprises devraient permettre au resto
du coeur de rester ouvert cet hiver une
belle initiative pourtant critiquer
notamment par les filles
député LFI qui dénonce un coup de com et
qui remercie la famille Arnaud pour
cette aumône remboursé à 66% par les
contribuables elle fait référence à la
réduction d'impôts prévus lors de dons à
des associations les bénéficiaires des
Restos du coeur ne cessent d'augmenter
cette année ça a été plus de 25% cet
hiver non non mais je suis toute seule
plus 25% au resto du coeur et on va nous
dire que Monsieur Bernard Arnault grâce
à lui donc effectivement les pauvres en
France ne peuvent pas se payer un sac
Louis Vuitton mais Bernard Arnault leur
offre des coquillettes lui sucré et ben
il est bien aimable et on va pas encore
lui dire merci
qui viennent pas nous faire son
opération comme avec son copain Macron
on sauve que la famille Arnaud a déjà
annoncé que sur une don ne donnerait
lieu à aucune contreparté contre parti
pardon et ni aucune défiscalisation et
la famille Arnaud n'est pas la seule à
mettre la main à la poche ce matin c'est
le groupe Crédit Mutuel qui vient en
aide à la Croix-Rouge également en
difficulté financière un don de 7
millions et demi d'euros va être fait
donc à la Croix-Rouge à la Croix-Rouge
de Courbevoie de plus en plus de
demandeurs mais moins de dons de la part
des grandes surfaces acheter pour
pouvoir répondre à la demande des
bénéficiaires qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux
et ça nous coûte de l'argent ça coûte de
plus en plus cher et on n'a pas le
budget je ne suis pas certaine qu'on
tiendra jusqu'à la fin de l'année au
premier semestre cette année plus 7% de
demandes mais les dépenses explosent
plus 45 millions d'euros rien que pour
les coûts de l'énergie la Croix-Rouge
s'attend un déficit de 50 millions
d'euros tout le monde il veut seulement
la tête et seulement ça ça les fait
bouger
à Mayotte département le plus pauvre de
France l'eau est devenu une denrée rare
pour tous les habitants depuis ce matin
plus d'eau robinet cette mère de famille
va devoir tenir 48 heures sans au
courant de l'eau un jour sur trois
seulement c'est la nouvelle règle une
catastrophe pour cette mère de trois
enfants
c'est très difficile avec les toilettes
surtout les toilettes je veux que on est
dès la 6ème de cette année qu'on
commence à avoir des élèves qui plantent
des arbres et qu'on est cette génération
où chaque collégien aura planté son
arbre ils vont nous aider à aller à
notre milliard de reboisement c'est
hyper important pour la Sainte Catherine
pourquoi pour l'instant de Catherine
tient quiz autour de cette table Patrick
Cohen non parce que à la Sainte
Catherine tout bois prend racine en fait
c'est fin novembre c'est la période
idoine pour planter un arbre c'est plus
l'état qui est au service de l'école
c'est l'école qui est au service de
l'État les élèves de 6e vont passer du
temps à planter des arbres pour reboiser
la France
dans les mettre dans des camps
c'est celui qui a pas envie de planter
un arbre
j'exagère sans doute un petit peu mais
pour toi
je vous présenterai mais oui mais le
truc c'est ça ça va exister mais c'est
des robots un petit peu plus long terme
des robots majordome qui pour le coup
pourront faire à peu près tout monter
les escaliers tout ce que vous voulez
mais je vous présenterai mais je vous
présenterai ça mais pour le concert
d'apprendre un petit peu plus de temps
voilà merci comme votre chronique merci
beaucoup
Anthony Morel